that's the worst when a guy you have a
conversation getting your hair cut and
he keeps having a conversation
that's that's the same way like tattoo
artists are the same way
oh yeah y'all got tatted yeah
what's our boy's name do you remember
jesse jessica what's his instagram man i
put in my instagram story i forget he
was great
dude great tattoo artist yeah great
artist
yeah i've seen you picture him and i'm
not i'm not making fun of jesse
it just is what it is anytime i've got a
tattoo you're doing a podcast
it is true that is life story true life
true life you're eating a full [ __ ]
rundown you ever like have like put your
headphones in and you just be
jamming you try to talk like all they
have time oh okay
all the time i'm like yo what am i gonna
do with this information
instagram uh i think we we we had to we
had it
is it on my story yeah so it's j e
underscore and three c's jake
underscores three c's
yeah let me go through this real quick
though he's really really no i wouldn't
be on there no
it's from the weekend yeah cops and
babies cops and babies
cops and babies both my father-in-law oh
oh that's what's up bro oh yeah you came
on this one with donuts
oh jay you underscored the three c's
cops yeah that's him right there that's
him
cops get free donuts right yeah usually
his work is good so he him like a couple
of
couple of artists like had hit me up in
my dm when you hit up every city we go
to
oh yeah people want to do tattoos on me
i thought it was like fake i was like
is that a serious thing but but i kept
getting uh quite a few of them that's a
dope
he was like yeah let me tattoo you and
brendan and i was like okay he's ready
uh brent and i looked at his work dude
came through he came through
clutch man chin i sent you mine okay um
yeah look at his stuff dude he's really
really good jay got one
didn't do that yeah was great he was
light-handed like
like it didn't even it wasn't even
painful yeah he's really [ __ ]
talented
yeah really from cali i told him he's
out here i'd be about to look like
travis parker in this [ __ ] oh
dude he's
he's that like ah that lion
i really thought that was faster i
really thought it was more possible
one day you would lead over the promised
land
anything that light touches oh okay it's
yours he's talented it's funny talented
as [ __ ] dude
shouts out to you but it doesn't matter
who it is it's not him or a barber
you're getting the full
[ __ ] oh you're getting the life story
yeah livestream and then after they tell
you their life story what are we
supposed to do with this information
yeah okay then it usually goes to sports
weather
that's mine right there man oh you
posted yours no i didn't it's a chance
that's what i got oh damn it's an oasis
song
so that's the oasis logo but it usually
says oasis in it but
i put one of my favorite oasis songs in
it you got a great skater
i know that's what he said he said you
got good skin you got great skin yeah i
was like i appreciate that it's like
just you know it's a good little melody
i just washed with cast style soap
justin got a tattoo yeah
yeah and your brother got the uh
checkered flags checkers
and you got the texas uh symbol look at
this texas logo the skull
skull on it it's badass he's man he he's
a good dude
i told him yeah i was like bro anytime i
come to texas you're the you're the man
100 percent
they love you down there in texas bro
that's my that's that's my [ __ ] that's
why you had the tattoo
because you love you you really love
this oh texas dude i love texas i would
say
one of my favorite one of my favorite
states that i've lived in is texas i
think
that's why i shoot my next special
probably oh dude the crowds for comedy
there
oh my god every night they were electric
dude right
they were shouting out stuff out before
you two near me not to hear me well
i just got hurt i just got up here so
funny yeah
yo i see y'all on youtube hear me i
swear to god he was like bro i gave you
you know i gave it a thumbs up 7
up thumbs up
just say you liked it i like that one
but when i get off stage at the lap
factory
right away you go bro i figure out what
you look like i'm like what just run a
bunch of other comics i'm like what
you're like
you look like a rottweiler you gotta
[ __ ] together
come on i'm just saying dude grab that
mic song